[Musica]
ciao a tutti grazie di avermi invitato
sono felicissimi di essere qui che
facciamo noi raccontiamo una storia che
ne dite allora
cominciamo
questa storia parte da questo anima
laccio qui allora questo qui è un
dinosauro e in particolare un
tyrannosaurus come tutti se lo
immaginano in particolare questo è
tratto da jurassic park
ecco secondo le ultime scoperte
scientifiche i dinosauri non erano così
oggi abbiamo tantissimo nuovo materiale
fossile tantissime nuove tecnologie che
ci fanno capire che questo non era del
rispetto di questi dinosauri in
particolare il tyrannosaurus appariva
più o meno così allora innanzitutto
vorrei parlare un attimo
dell'ambientazione in cui è questo
dinosauro perché notate chi è in una
foresta in una foresta lussureggiante
perché dobbiamo intendere il mondo di un
tempo il mondo di prima di 65 milioni di
anni fa come un mondo lussureggiante
pieno di vita pieno di foreste e non
come un mondo costituito da deserti
vulcani gas letali nell'aria come è
sempre stato raffigurato invece nara un
mondo e lussureggiante e pieno di vita e
in particolare questo dinosauro questo
tyrannosaurus lo potete vedere come
coperto da una sorta di pelliccia questa
pelliccia sono delle proto piume proto
piume che vuol dire prima delle piume
erano questi filamenti che gli
permettevano di mantenere il calore
corporeo
ecco questo è un altro dinosauri in
particolare velociraptor atto da
jurassic ward che ha visto questi film
ed è appassionato di fantascienza lo
conosce benissimo ecco però queste
realtà non era il vero aspetto di un
velociraptor perché gli scienziati hanno
scoperto che molti di questi dinosauri
erano carnivori quindi significa che
cacciavano altri altri animali quindi
correvano molto avevano un metabolismo
accelerato metabolismo vuol dire
capacità di assorbire energia e quindi
si muovevano velocemente ed erano a
sangue caldo quindi omeoterma
più scientifico quindi significa che il
calore che emetteva il corpo lo
utilizzavano però voi immaginate perciò
il corpo di questi animali come anche
quello dei mammiferi come una grande
stanza con una stufa a legna accesa se
voi c'e niente la stufa e il corpo si
riscalda ma se voi tenete le finestre
spalancate il calore che cosa fa si
disperde all'esterno invece i dinosauri
mettendo un invenzione veramente
importante non faceva altro che chiudere
queste finestre e così utilizzare il
calore che producevano e perciò le piume
e quindi noi possiamo vedere un
velociraptor di moltissimi milioni di
anni fa come questo un dinosauro piumato
molto a te più bello più sgargiante per
così dire quindi questi dinosauri erano
veloci avevano un metabolismo accelerato
cacciavano altri animali quindi dobbiamo
intendere dinosauri non più come
creature orribili
orripilanti ma invece come degli esseri
intelligenti agili e soprattutto piumati
allora questi filamenti questi queste
piume questi filamenti che si sono
creati hanno avuto origine 220 milioni
di anni fa quindi stiamo parlando
tantissimo tempo in un piccolo
animaletto quello che vedete le era una
lucertolina più o meno grande così che
saltava da un ramo all'altro degli
alberi presentava questo film in questi
filamenti questa pelliccia per mantenere
il calore corporeo e non disperderlo
all'esterno da questo piccolo animale si
sono evoluti gli etero sauri come quello
lassù che quindi sono dei rettili
volanti quelli che spesso vengono
confusi con dinosauri o con uccelli e
poi anche i dinosauri che hanno
ereditato questa caratteristica
ecco piano piano nei dinosauri questi
filamenti diventavano un po più ampi si
ramifica vano si creavano le prime piume
e le prime penne che erano sulle zampe
anteriori allora voi immaginate di
essere un piccolo dinosauro come questi
che avete sulle zampe anteriori cioè le
vostre braccia queste penne queste belle
penne tutte colorate che cosa fate le
utilizzate nella comunicazione per
mandare segnali ecco ed è per questo che
i dinosauri avevano queste grandi
superfici che utilizzavano come dico io
un po come dei cartelli pubblicitari
cioè per mandare i segnali per
scoraggiare un predatore che magari li
vuole mangiare oppure per per fare le
parate di corteggiamento e attrarre il
partner per tanti motivi in questa
raffigurazione vedere questo dinosauro
che sta praticamente sul mito con delle
uova il nome di questo dinosauro è ovi
raptor ovi l'actor significa al ladro di
uova e quindi perché il suo fossile è
stato ritrovato su un nido con delle
uova e si pensava che questo dinosauro
le stesse andando a rubare per
mangiarselo poi però si è scoperto che
non era proprio così in realtà questo
dinosauro restava comando stava covando
e le proprie uova quindi utilizzava
questo strumento queste piume non solo
per scaldare se stessa ma anche le
proprie uova e questo è importantissimo
perché ci fa capire anche l'intelligenza
all'accudimento della prole nei
dinosauri
e poi si ha portato a quello che tutti
noi conosciamo negli uccelli odierni che
è il volo però capite che in realtà le
piume non sono state utilizzate dai
dinosauri subito per volare ma in realtà
per molti altri scopi importantissimi
questo è il fossile di archi op erix
marchiò perché è stato scoperto nel 1861
ed una delle prime persone che prese in
mano questo fossile fu charles darwin
charles darwin fu uno scienziato molto
importante e molto famoso che fu colui
che ha teorizzato insomma che ha
ipotizzato la teoria dell'evoluzione che
oggi più che teoria la voglio chiamare
in realtà perché il cuore pulsante della
scienza di oggi ecco e guardando questo
fossile lui capire ancora di più e poter
fermare ancora di più la teoria
dell'evoluzione che in quel momento
era in fase di sviluppo era in fase di
evoluzione appunto e guardate questo
fossile poi vedete proprio lo scheletro
di un dinosauro però guardate le zampe
anteriori e la coda si vedono questi
queste strisce questi filamenti
ramificati quelle non sono altro che
penn pn fossilizzate e questo fossile è
stato scoperto nel 1861 eppure non molte
persone ancora oggi sanno che da
dinosauri si sono evoluti gli uccelli e
che i dinosauri non erano creature ribi
l'anti ma invece piumate e sgargianti
ecco e quindi possiamo dire che charles
darwin e altri scienziati chiamarono
questo fossile l'anello di congiunzione
fra di noi e uccelli oggi questo termine
non viene più utilizzato però è per far
capire ancora di più come avviene
l'evoluzione ecco guardate questo
ambiente questa foresta lussureggiante
che è di oggi che sarà foto di questi
ultimi anni però dobbiamo immaginare il
mondo in cui si sono evoluti i primi
uccelli ricordo sempre nella radio
dinosauri quindi sopra le teste di
tyrannosaurus dobbiamo immaginare il
mondo in cui si sono evoluti i primi
uccelli come in questo modo pieno di
aree pieno di habitat che hanno di
nicchie ecologiche l'amica ecologica che
è una parola difficile lo so però
significa praticamente la posizione di
una specie all'interno di un ecosistema
il lavoro che è una specie fa
nell'ecosistema e quindi gli uccelli
visto che potevano volare avevano voluto
il volo si diversificarono in tantissime
forme differenti e questo evento viene
detto dagli scienziati board boom ossia
l'esplosione degli uccelli in parole
povere proprio per stare a significare
che si crearono un sacco di specie
uccelli acquatici uccelli che abitavano
i boschi e cioè li cacciano gli insetti
in aria tantissime specie
guardate quest'altro fossili questa foto
è di un fossile si vede benissimo si
vedono questi filamenti un po più scuri
che partono dalla zampa anteriore di
questo primo uccello che si è evoluto
lancio ormis ecco questi filamenti sono
delle penne fossilizzate ecco che cosa
hanno fatto gli scienziati all'inizio un
po per gioco hanno iniziato ad
analizzare nel dettaglio queste penne
fossilizzate e hanno trovato indovinate
cosa il paradiso dei melanosomi
praticamente melanosomi sono quei gli
organuli che nelle cellule danno il
pigmento quindi che rendono colorate le
piume
ecco e quindi
analizzando la forma di questi milano
sommi licenziati sono riuscite a capire
come di che colore era questo dinosauro
e quindi noi sappiamo per certezza o
quasi che questo dinosauro questo primo
uccello aveva questi colori vedete anche
una grassa rossa che magari veniva
utilizzata durante le parate di
corteggiamento
ecco e poi arriva la data quella che
tutti noi conosciamo cioè
dell'estinzione dei dinosauri no adesso
ho capito che non è stato proprio così
estinzione non la dovremmo chiamare
perché in questo periodo
c'erano moltissimi uccelli e noi
dobbiamo intendere gli uccelli non come
semplicemente the discendente dei
dinosauri ma un gruppo di dinosauri
perché in quel periodo prima del
dell'arrivo 65 milioni di anni fa di
questo corpo celeste che impatto sulla
terra
dobbiamo intendere gli uccelli come uno
di questi gruppi dinosauri c'erano i
dinosauri erbivori cern i dinosauri
carnivori poi c'erano anche gli uccelli
che abitavano i cieli e non è quindi
quando avvenne questa catastrofe
chiaramente gli animali quelli che erano
che si potevano adattare meglio alle co
sistemi nuovi che si formavano dopo
questo cataclisma e quindi il gruppo di
dinosauri quello che riusciva ad
adattarsi meglio quello che era più
specializzato più
anche flessibile che così si poteva
adattare ai nuovi ambienti che si
creavano erano gli uccelli quindi gli
uccelli furono il solo gruppo di
dinosauri chi riuscì a sopravvivere e
che non sono altro che gli antenati di
tutti gli uccelli che conosciamo noi
oggi che sono insomma 10.000
e centinaia di specie insomma più di
10.000 però se continuiamo così nei
prossimi anni saranno un po di meno
comunque
questo è arriva quindi vedere tutta
questa storia bellissima dell'evoluzione
degli uccelli che combattevano con altri
animali per il dominio dei cieli e poi
che cosa fa che cosa fa non riescono a
resistere ad un estensione di mans e poi
arriva arriva l'ultima arriva l'uomo
arriva l'uomo che insomma gli uccelli
stanno un po faticando per rimanere nel
loro luogo nel luogo in cui si sono
evoluti nei cieli nelle foreste negli
stagni mei nei mari ecco ed è per questo
anche che domani
l'uomo a istinto moltissime specie di
animali ma estinguendo una specie non si
fa un danno solamente a quella specie ma
si fa un danno in generale per tutto
l'ecosistema che chiaramente è legato a
questa specie alla presenza di questa
specie
alcuni uccelli che si sono estinti ma
qui posso dilungarmi tantissimo sono il
moa il dodo che erano questo si conosce
no è conosciuto che viveva nell'isola di
mauritius oppure l'altra impegni che era
simile a un pinguino matera alta abitava
il polo nord e tanti altri insomma
arriva poi arrivano gli ultimi decenni
perché la maggior parte di
dell'intervento dell'uomo sulla natura
disastrosa è avvenuto negli ultimi
decenni con deforestazioni riscaldamento
globale e tantissimi altri problemi che
insomma noi siamo qui anche per parlarne
per discuterne per cercare di trarre dei
modi per invertire la rotta per così
dire quindi ricordate sempre che se
anche vedete insomma una gallina e che
per voi magari un mezzo per fare affari
pure oppure per riempire la pancia e non
vi dico niente però ricordatevi che è un
discendente dei dinosauri
insomma ah sì
prima ho dimenticato di dire chi sono
allora io sono francesco barberini ho 14
anni sono divulgatore scientifico cioè
faccio quello che ho fatto adesso
insomma racconto la natura e io mi batto
chiaramente anche per la protezione
dell'ambiente e per la salvaguardia
dell'ambiente e poi dico anche per la
salvaguardia delle generazioni future
insomma per cercare di
di permettere anche alle generazioni che
verranno in futuro di vedere il mondo
così come lo vediamo noi oggi e quindi
niente io ho girato tutto il mondo ho
fatto tutto il mondo no siamo chiari
vorrei insomma spero quindi per fare
conferenze per portare questo messaggio
insomma sono alfiere della repubblica
italiana per meriti scientifici
divulgativi però insomma stati
tranquilli non è che faccio niente di
strano se sono alfiere della repubblica
però ho capito che ho un compito cioè il
compito di portare tra le persone la
natura
quindi faccio divulgazione un suo amico
di piero angela abbiamo chiacchierato un
po e lui mi ha spiegato ancora meglio
che cosa significa divulgare come lo
faccio nel mio ultimo libro che sa che
fine hanno fatto i dinosauri appunto
dove racconto questa storia quella che
vi ho raccontato adesso è insomma niente
ciò che io porto è la natura come ho
detto ma un altro messaggio che è molto
importante e conosce la natura perché
come dico sempre se la natura la conosci
la me e se la ami la protegge grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]